Double Fine's darling platformer with  psychic kids is over ten years old and  we're finally getting a lot of news  about the sequel I'm Tony and this is  your doubly fine GameSpot news update  first up we've learned that star breeze  the publisher behind payday 2 will also  be publishing Psychonauts - it's coming  to ps4 Xbox one and PC in 2018 and  although the title will still be  property of Double Fine star breeze will  put eight million dollars of its own  money behind the project on top of that  project lead Zack McClendon and Double  Fine boss Tim Schafer showed off some  new gameplay of the games test  environment you can get a first look and  how protagonist Raz moves and jumps  across tight ropes and other platforms  Psychonauts 2 was fully funded on Figg  more than a year ago so additional  backing from star breeze can only help  you can expect plenty more information  before the game drops in 2018 and to  keep up with all of it you're already in  the right place  you